hello zombie apocolypse fans right so I
got to be clear this is a review of The
Walking Dead game not the TV series but
the video game I would probably piss
some people off and other people will be
overjoyed by it but you can just so we
know for now let's talk about this game
that everyone seems to be talking about
The Walking Dead so the Walking Dead
video games start out amidst the
beginning of the zombie apocalypse and
you're a criminal namely of course
you're going to play as a convicted
criminals either convicted criminal or
cop those are your two zombie apocolypse
option or nerd who ends up getting Emma
Stone I know only in the zombie
apocalypse
long story short in a nutshell leave
runs across a girl named Clementine and
he's ultimately trying to get her to her
parents and in that you meet some
friends you get some allies you make a
camp and then you uproot and you have
your Walking Dead video game now what
really surprises me is that the game is
really fun and entertaining and all it
is is a point and click game you don't
have a menu system you don't have a
series of weapons you get you can't just
open fire on zombies unless the game
says hey now is the time you can open
fire on zombies and even then more or
less you just run or beat them with
wrenches and even even then you really
just really run it's one of those games
where you have things on the screen you
can interact with so you click on it
it's like oh that's a wrench you go over
here click on that oh that's a coffee
table you go over to a person you click
on them and then you have a bunch of
dialogue options you can talk to them
eighty-five to ninety percent of the
game is dialogue I mean the entire
game's dialogue base but that's really
where the game shines you know how a lot
of games make the claim to like hey what
you do in this game really is going to
affect the game later on and you're like
well I guess it kind of does but no
matter who I choose by the third game
gudinas gonna end up being on the
council anyway so did it matter but in
the Walking Dead you really feel like
what you do matters the first zombie I
killed I just beat his head in with a
hammer it was like Clementine will
remember that I'm like what do you what
do you mean she will remember that I
don't know if that really matters but it
was kind of like what do you mean the
kids did I scar her for life I would
hate the thing that was true although
she's probably gonna see worship by the
end but of course you're like oh I'm
gonna be your buddy because you're a
nice person I'm gonna be your buddy - oh
now they're at odds you have to pick a
side that always sucks ass it's a really
volatile mix among your crew and you
will end up siding with people you
didn't expect to side with and then
people will die and you're like that
with that person's dead and I really
mean dad - I don't want to call the
people you meet in The Walking Dead
expendable income but they kind of are
they're more relevant than that so
calling them that kind of cuts them
short but they can die there will be
people were you like he could have died
an episode ago or he can live to the end
of the next episode you don't know
you'll be holding someone over a Ledge
and there's a bunch of zombies there and
you're like I could let him go he
screwed up a couple times so yeah I
might be justified in letting him go but
if you do you got to deal with
consequences and all that unhappy [ __ ]
now I say episode because the game
breaks itself up among five episodes and
the cool gimmick of the whole thing is
an episode came out every month and a
half or two months or so so people would
play one episode each episodes only like
a couple hours long it doesn't take you
too long to beat in episode and they're
just on pins and needles they're like I
want to play the next episode have to
wait oh [ __ ] it's coming out and getting
really pumped and then that day comes
where you can get the new episode and
they download it like at midnight that
night as much as people hate it they
actually love it they love to hate it
and hate to love it that's a really cool
element that's really fun and I like
that I missed out on that because I just
downloaded every episode immediately and
I was like I'll just play them all back
to back when you see pictures of The
Walking Dead or footage you'll I got
cel-shaded cartoon [ __ ] it's not
actually gonna do the walking dead
justice no what completely and totally
does I mean I imagine they did it this
way because it takes less production to
get it done they don't have to find
detail everyone's skin pores and doesn't
take nine years to make there are a
couple times in this game my job was on
the floor I was just like I can't
believe that just happened
well it takes a lot for a game to drive
me to that point I was genuinely in
disbelief of the situation and where the
game really shines is the relationship
between Lee and Clementine the
relationship between the character you
play and this little girl it had to be
good otherwise this game would just be
completely forgettable like oh yeah they
really tried with that but not really no
you really care about her and she does
affect the way you play the game there
are some messed up people in this game
there was this one guy he was on his
knees I had a pitchfork to his chest and
I stabbed him in the chest and
Clementine was behind me I didn't know
it was like it was a Clementine saw that
she runs off and I was like I reset I
didn't know she was there and so I had
the guy at pitchfork length and I was
like no I'm not killing you because of
her it's kind of cool with a little girl
in a game who doesn't really exist does
influence how you play the game there
are some people in the game you're like
yeah you deserve to be offed but I have
to be a good example to Clementine cuz I
care cuz she's awesome but I like the
fact that you can't baby her either
because this is a zombie apocalypse so
you're like Clem you need to toughen up
and you need to learn how to
shoot guns and hit zombies and shoot
them in the face yeah Coulter Clem we're
cool like that you will be to play the
game like you should this game is like
the Dark Horse of the years everyone's
like oh Mass Effect 3 game of the year
this game game of the year that game is
gonna be game of the year then The
Walking Dead kind of sneaks in it's like
hey we're awesome and more people are
starting to play it they're like yeah
this this is pretty awesome
I don't know if it's gonna get game of
the year based on the fact that it's not
a very involved game in terms of
structure and menu systems and weapons
system it's a point and click game the
game shines where it needs to shine it
doesn't promise to be anything other
than a point and click game but as far
as point and click games go it's gonna
be the best one you're gonna get usually
point-and-click dialog based games like
this really overdo it what you can do is
like open the fridge pull out the milk
pull off the milk cap drink the milk put
the milk cap back on put the milk back
in the fridge walk over to the table you
didn't close the fridge door close the
fridge it gets really annoying this game
simplifies it's like all right point
click on what you need get what you need
talk with who you need to talk to you
know not everyone's going to jump into
this game be like oh yeah it's totally
awesome I'm sure people want their
involved menus and their Mass Effect
zombie game it's not going to be like
that it's just a dialogue driven point
and click game that being said it's
certainly one of the most memorable
games I've played lately and I'm gonna
play through this game again that is
saying something
the most memorable episode in the entire
game episode 2 I think everyone's going
to unanimously be like yeah episode 2 is
that that's that's messed up I'm going
to give a point and click game this I
really don't care this game had me
almost at tears a couple times I'm
pretty sure at the end actual tears not
man tears or any cop out like that not
just tears the Walking Dead video game
is awesome tacular
to the Walking Dead video game have you
played it and if you have what's your
favorite episode of the entire thing I'm
really curious about that whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more